what sources do you go to when you say
you're researching what do you read are
you a Zero Hedge guy are you a Wall
Street Journal what do you what do you
read
you know I'm I'm scanning everything on
Bloomberg News I'm scanning everything
on the Wall Street Journal home page I'm
scanning the news feeds on anything
related to bitcoin
um I'm scanning uh you know the major
papers the the New York time to see what
they're thinking I'm I'm scanning
Twitter what they're thinking it's
useful to know what they print right on
the New York Times thinking like they do
a lot of so uh yeah we could go there
yeah but you don't think you could use
everything in New York Times the point
is the point is what's what's on the
front page like what is what is the
narrative on the front page what is on
the front page of the Wall Street what's
the paper that what's a paper you read
that's like not a common paper like is
there some a site or a journalist you
trust somebody that writes that you
follow an expert I don't I don't think
you could I don't think you could in
good faith endorse any any one news
Outlet in the modern world I think I
think uh you have to scan everything and
you have to consider what statistically
significant and of course what you find
in the in the news media is oftentimes
it if 92 percent of the people are dying
of natural causes
95 percent of the bandwidth it bleeds at
least 95 of the bandwidth is the most
colorful way to die
right it's the not the most likely way
to die it's the most colorful way to die
and so I I think that all all media is
distorted and they're they're all edited
and they're all focused to a certain
agenda the only thing you can reasonably
do is you can scan a bunch of them you
can scan you know your own Twitter feed
will also be distorted so you have to
scan other feeds and then you have to be
continually going through this exercise
in your head of saying
that happened is it true
and then how significant is it for for
example
Argentine inflation 105 is it true no
Because the actual inflation rate is
higher it's it's indicative of a truth
how significant is it well how many
people live in Argentina
that's one level of significance the
second is how much money's in Argentina
and the third level significance is how
and you know how symbolic or or how how
indicative or catalytic is it to other
activity that will happen the rest of
the world right how symbolic is it so
you
I I think that
I'm in my 50s I'm 58.
if if everybody's worth by the way
February fourth same birthday is May
that's right if you roll the clock back
and you read the the same newspaper in
your teens you'll interpret something
different if you read news in your 20s
it's different and your 30s it's
different in your 40s it's different
powerful when you get to your 50s if you
read the same like you read the same
history book and you're reading it in
your 50s like wow I totally interpreted
this differently when I was a ninth
grader right when I was in college I
interpreted this differently so you have
to have real world experience oftentimes
you'll read a story and they'll State
something and the truth is the exact
opposite of what the story is
but you have to have lived life like for
example you read a headline uh we found
500 Stone axes in a cave in Africa
they're between 1.2 and 1.7 million
years old
well
a school kid will say oh yeah so I guess
they found some Stone axes
I look at that and I say well there was
a factory that made Stone axes in Africa
1.7 million years ago that meant that
there was demand for thousands of stone
axes a year that meant that there was an
entire civilization that existed right
in fact there was money there was a
government there was a Furniture Factory
there was a clothing Factory there was a
there was agriculture there was an
entire Society you had to have 10 000
people all working together in
coordination to justify having an
inventory of 500 Stone axes
right and the only reason you actually
read about the stone axes is the stone
ax is the only thing that's going to
last a million years from now right and
so what was there was a thousand acts
more interesting the fact is there was
an interesting higher level civilization
with agriculture one and a half million
years ago they're not writing that in
the history book because the literal
historian only wants to report the bare
minimum but the reason that I could
actually tell you
thousand other things
is that I actually read books on
Austrian economics I you know I ran a
business I traded I saw the the Meltdown
and and the uh the creation of dozens of
of Industries
and I understand human nature
right and so if you understand you know
and you live the life you're like well
if I you know if I drink cartons of
orange juice every day for months in a
row I know what's going to happen to me
it's not good
you can reverse that right and you can
figure out what people ate a hundred
thousand years ago you know you they did
they didn't do the things that we don't
really think are good ideas today
because they wouldn't appropriated
through a hundred thousand Generations
so I think that when you read the news
in your 50s if you've lived a life and
by the way like a lot of things I
interpret are because I ran a company
for 30 years
you know like for example you know like
a teenager yeah if you look at movies
created by people in their 20s they have
this view of business people like the
badass billionaire business guy walks in
and ever and he tells everybody what to
think and they you know and he's the you
know he's the evil Dr Evil Genius but if
you've actually run a business you know
I remember back last time I told
somebody what to think and they told me
to go f myself
right and then you know and you are
dressed in black you know you're and now
I have a meeting and and I'm very polite
you know like and the more talented you
are the more polite I am you know
because I realize that the world will go
on without me
like the those people think oh yeah well
I gotta work for the man well no you
don't I have 2 000 people in my company
right now I have hired 30 000 people
they don't have to work for the man
right the truth is unbelievable point
you know you hire people you realize
that they are they will quit if they
don't like the seal gets fired more
often than employees do yeah yeah I lost
27 500 employees all right so you you
think I take them for granted yeah
but but you have but I but I didn't when
I was 24 like what a perspective the
time when you are most confident when
you have the most amount of formal
education and the least amount of Real
World Experience like in your early 20s
right because you think you can do it
better than everybody else and you
haven't failed
and when you get another 25 years out
you're like oh I tried that that didn't
work I tried that that didn't work I
tried that that didn't work oh yeah that
was a really good employee but they quit
because I was rude to them oops I wish I
hadn't done that
oops took that for granted so
I guess I'm coming back to your question
how what do I think about the news it's
like can you give us one name one source
like do you go to something that's not
the traditional one everybody else goes
to any person I know it's not 100
accuracy you trust but give us one sword
I I I think I think to give a boost to
Twitter and Elon Musk the Boost is there
are analysts and there are domain
experts on Twitter that don't have
corporations that don't have lawyers to
tell them they're not allowed to say
that thing and they actually say the
truth can you give us their names a
couple of them Michael I want to hold
you to give us one name no no give us
follow me on Twitter I mean you can look
at all
about 600 people okay so then follow the
people you're following there are honest
analysts and there are people that are
domain experts and they publish their
unadulterated thoughts and if you
actually put together a mosaic of all
those things with your own Real World
Experience you'll start to synthesize a
viewer of reality which is I think
probably more reliable than any one you
know edited traditional media source so
if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
foreign